نعود الى الحرب في اوكرانيا لا من زاويه
التطورات الميداليه بالبنزاويه المخاوف
التي احيتها هذه الحرب بالامكانيه وقوع
نزاع نوويه فما الذي حدث الرابع والعشرين
من شباط فبراير بدات روسيا حربا على
اوكرانيا فجرت ازمه غير مسبوقه منذ نهايه
الحرب البارده يقول مساعد الامين العام
السابق لحلف شمال الاطلسي كامل القران هي
المره الاولى منذ بدايه العصر النووي التي
تشن فيه قوه نوويه عربا تقليديه مستدله
بالمظله النوويه في عام 2002 2020 لم
تتردد قنوات تلفزيونيه روسيه في استحضار
احتمالات التوجيه ضربه النوويه على باريس
او نيويورك بين بقاله دبلوماسيون روسي
يضغط على الزر اذا اعتبر ان روسيا مهدده
بالاختفاء وفي ظل ضغوط على موسكو لوحه
الرئيس الروسي نفسه بورقه الاس النووي
قائلا انه مستعد لاستخدام كل الوسائل
المتاحه في ترسانته هذه الاجواء
والتهديدات والتلميحات دفعت الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدل الى التحذير في تشييد
الاول اكتوبر الماضي من كارثه نوويه
محتمله
وامس فقط قال وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
لافروف ان الغرب يخاطر بصدام مباشر بين
القوه النوويه ستكون له عواقب وقيمه وفي
ظل هذه الاجواء يصبح السؤال ما هو مستقبل
معاهده منع انتشار الاسلحه النوويه الاداه
الحيويه للامني الدوليه
يعكس مؤتمر مراجعه معاهده حظر الانتشار
النووي الذي عقدته الامم المتحده في اب
اغسطس المخاوف من الاضطرابات الجاريه في
الساحه الدوليه فقد منعت روسيا اعلان
المشتركا للدول الموقعه وعددها 191 هو
تحولا تحول في موقف موسكو الذي كان
تاريخيا دائما لمعاهده حظر الانتشار
النووي وقبل ايام قليله ارجاء روسيا
محادثات مع الولايات المتحده حول معاهده
نيوز ستارت وهي اخر معاهده رئيسيه للنزع
السلاح بين اكبر قوتين نووييتين كوريا
الشماليه على حد المخاوف فقد اعلنت في
ايلول سبتمبر ان وضعها الجديد بوصفها قوه
النوويه هو امر لا رجوع فيها لتغلق بذلك
نهائيا الباب امام اي مفاوضات بشان نزع
سلاحها ثم توعدت في يونج واشنطن بيرد
النووي في حاله وقوعه
على ارضها ختاما نتوقف مع مفهوم الاخلاق
وصلتجي يشر له بالمحرمات النوويه بشان عدم
استخدام السلاحي الذري والذي تبلور بعد
القصف الامريكي لهيروشيما ونكزكي في عام
45 والسؤال هل لا يزال هذا المفهوم قائما
ام ان ما تغير فقط هو الخطاب والسجاد